[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation dans la bataille pour la
suprématie mondiale entre les etats-unis
et la chine dans les 30 prochaines
années
deux événements majeurs viennent de se
produire qui éclaire la politique
chinoise et modifie complètement les
rapports de force que nous avions déjà
évoqué lors de notre émission sur lyon
pour bien comprendre ce qui se passe il
faut se rappeler que dans son histoire
la chine a été la première puissance
mondiale par sa taille et son commerce
elle était talonnée par l'inde jusqu'en
1793 citons bas sous la domination de la
couronne britannique
le déclin a commencé en 1840
quand les anglais lui ont fait la guerre
et l'ont déstabilisé car l'empereur de
chine
ce qu'on ne sait pas voulait interdire
la consommation d'opium importées
frauduleusement depuis l'inde par les
britanniques au niveau militaire
la chine n'a jamais fait la guerre hors
de ses frontières
à la différence des états unis qui les
ont enchaîné en application de leur
stratégie de puissance mondiale
aujourd'hui avec 261 milliards de
dollars de dépenses militaires soit 1,9
pour cent leur produit intérieur brut
elle est loin derrière les états unis
avec leur 732 milliards de dollars qui
représente 3,4 pour cent de leur pib
selon la banque mondiale s'appuyant sur
leur concept de guerre hors limites
inquiète officialisé en 1999 et qui
ensuite inspiré l'armée russe
il est clair que les chinois ont deux
objectifs militaires à travers ces
investissements pouvoir se défendre
efficacement face à l'attack d'un ennemi
supérieur en puissance et assurer la
sécurité de leurs lignes
d'approvisionnement en énergie qui
recoupe partiellement des routes de la
soie terrestres et maritimes
souvenons nous qu'en dépit de sunu et
son art de la guerre que tout le monde
connaît les chinois ne sont pas des
guerriers loin d'un expansionnisme
militaire dénoncé par la propagande
occidentale
ce sont avant tout des commerçants et on
peut le dire sans nul doute parmi les
meilleurs si la chine a toujours affirmé
depuis times yahoo bing le successeur de
mao qu'elle voulait retrouver son niveau
de puissance mondiale
l'actuel président xi jinping
a précisé lors de son installation sa
volonté de réalisation du rêve chinois
et qui est je le rappelle le
développement de la croissance
économique qui apportera un bien-être
supplémentaire au peuple tandis qu'on
réhabilitera la culture traditionnelle
deuxième puissance économique planétaire
la chine va réaliser cette année le
meilleur résultat économique des pays du
g20 puisqu'elle devrait être le seul
état positif avec +1 1,9 pour cent selon
le fmi
et elle annonce 8% de croissance en 2021
l'assureur crédit euler indique qu'elle
représentera cette année 25% du total
des exportations dans le monde alors
qu'elle n'avait que 20 % avant la
pandémie selon le quotidien suisse le
matin qui a été confirmé par eurostat
la chine est également devenu au
troisième trimestre 2020 le plus gros
client de l'europe avec 4 125,5
milliards d'euros devant les etats-unis
qui n'ont fait que tout est relatif 413
5 milliard d' euros d' échanges
commerciaux mais la balance est
déséquilibré car le niveau d'achat de
produits européens par les chinois est
inférieur de 45 % aux achats de produits
chinois par les européens dans ce cadre
la chine depuis quatre ans il ne faut
pas l'oublier le premier partenaire
commercial de l'allemagne avec un volume
d'échangés en 2019 de 206 milliards de
dollars selon le site atlantico et elle
est même devenue son premier marché
export au deuxième trimestre 2020 alors
ceci explique bien entendu la prudence
de la chancelière face aux pressions
américaines et d'autres pays de l'union
quand on parle de la chine comme le
rappelle mary françoise renard
professeur à l'université d'auvergne
il ne faut pas pour autant sous-estimer
les difficultés structurelles que
connaît la chine malgré une embellie
conjoncturelle renforcée par une sortie
de crise sanitaire réussi savez s'il ne
disent pas tout les chinois annoncent
toujours ce qu'ils vont faire
avant de le réaliser il est donc très
important d'analyser les résultats de la
5ème session plénière qui a préparé le
20ème congrès 2022
réunis à beijing du 26 au 29 octobre les
364 membre du comité central du parti
communiste ont adopté les objectifs de
développement économique et social
chinois du plan quinquennal national qui
va de 2021 à 2025 et les priorités
économiques des dix années suivantes
tirons les enseignements de leurs
difficiles relations
je dirais même très difficiles relations
avec les états unis du président trump
et les pays qui les soutiennent
il confirme la relance en cours de leur
marché intérieur notamment en matière de
consommation et ceci est rendu possible
par la montée de la classe moyenne qui
devrait atteindre 7 123 millions
d'individus en 2028 selon les échos
alors on peut les comparer aux 600
millions de chinois vivent actuellement
avec un revenu mensuel de 140 dollars ou
avec les 741 millions de la totalité de
la population européenne actuelle russie
comprise dans cet énorme marché
intérieur il semble avoir atteint
l'étape intermédiaire fixé par les plans
quinquennaux précédent à savoir le
niveau suffisant pour le développement
urbain et les villes nouvelles de la
compétitivité de l'industrie face aux
concurrents étrangers et la capacité de
recherche qui en fait le premier
dépositaire de brevets au monde
sur cette base ils vont dorénavant
accélérer la transition écologique et
sur investir dans le numérique pour
répondre aux interdictions américaine en
supprimant toute dépendance dans les
cinq ans à venir ici seront aidés par la
taille du marché des internautes chinois
qui en 2020 at 1 904 millions
d'individus contre si on compare 500
millions en europe 501 millions en
europe sont aux futures attaques
et 279 selon sera tista aux états unis
dans le fond la tacc brutale contre
huawei leur a ouvert les yeux et leur a
rendu service
parce qu'ils vont ressortir beaucoup
plus fort
en matière de développement
technologique les chinois planifient la
mise en oeuvre des ressources leur
permettant d'atteindre l'autonomie et ne
fait aucun doute qu'ils utiliseront tous
les moyens pour atteindre le niveau
requis en dépit des efforts de
rattrapage occidentaux ils vont
continuer à contrôler le marché des
terres rares qui sont un enjeu majeur
pour la souveraineté des pays et la
résilience de leur économie
il faut rappeler qu'il maîtrise
directement au moins 62 % de
l'extraction minière mondiale de tera
est probablement 88 3% selon l' agence
de l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie
si l'on y ajoute la séparation et le
traitement comme le rappelle bastien
bourges pour le club risque de
l'association de l'école de guerre
économique
ces 17 éléments chimiques sont
essentiels pour les gars femme ça nous
le savons mais aussi pour les moteurs de
voitures électriques pour les satellites
les lasers ou les produits militaires
dans le domaine sensible des énergies
fossiles la corde troc avec l'iran et
les relations avec la russie
leur permet d'avoir dorénavant un
approvisionnement énergétique suffisant
et qui se fera non seulement par les
routes maritimes actuels mais aussi par
des oléoducs et gazoducs venant d'iran
et de russie enfin ils vont quand tu
l'aies la mise en place méthodique des
routes de la soie qui l'ont appuyé cette
année par une politique d' aide
sanitaire aux pays amis et aux pays
cibles comme ils l'ont fait avec
l'italie et la serbie ou aussi par la
création de liens financiers et
commerciaux s'appuyant sur un plan
d'action conjoint
on l'a vu avec le 3e forum sur la
coopération sino-africaine en septembre
regroupant 53 pays africains ou dans les
encore globaux avec l'iran
à moyen terme il est clair que les
stratèges chinois vise un fort
développement des relations économiques
avec l'europe qui reste un des trois
plus gros marché mont
où et avec l'afrique qu'elle continue en
devenir face à cette pression constante
après un forum franco africain de bamako
en demi-teinte faut bien le dire en 2017
la fin du franc cfa le 20 mai 2020 et
l'annulation du forum de cette année à
bordeaux
il est clair que la france a perdu sa
position de référence auprès des états
du sud de la méditerranée au niveau
européen il est indéniable que l'absence
d'unité de vue avec nos partenaires dans
les réponses à apporter nous fragilise
face aux attentes des pays africains en
développement et facilite le rôle de la
chine et sa stratégie
dans le cadre de sa politique de
containment vis-à-vis de la chine le
président obama avait conclu le 4
février 2016 un traité de commerce le
transpacifique par marcher avec douze
pays de la zone asie-pacifique afin
d'accroître les échanges et réduire leur
dépendance de la chine
il a été dénoncé par le président trump
le 23 janvier 2017 et les chinois qui
avait fait une première tentative sans
succès au 19e sommet de l'association
des nations de l'asie du sud est ce
qu'on appelle la zean à bali en 2011 ce
sont bien entendu engouffrés dans cette
brèche
ils ont négocié avec quinze pays le
partenariat régional économique globale
qu'on appelle le rce paix qui crée la
plus grande zone de libre échange du
monde
rendez vous compte un espace économique
occupé par 2 milliards 200 millions
d'habitants qui représente 30% de la
production mondiale de richesse
l'annnonce de sa signature par vidéo à
hanoi le 15 novembre 2020 bouleverse les
équilibres mondiaux et consacre la perte
d'influencé américaine dans cette partie
du monde
n'oublions pas que barack obama il le
rappelle dans ses mémoires et son vice
président joe biden avait fait de l'asie
le pivot de leur politique
internationale en laissant tomber
l'europe en dehors d'action sur les pays
frontières avec la russie face à la
création du rcb annoncé juste après son
élection comme par hasard le président
joe biden aura bien du mal à trouver une
alternative crédible et durable
alors que son pays est en proie aux
divisions et aux règlements de comptes
dans les 15 signataires de l'accord on
trouve bien entendu la chine mais aussi
singapour la malaisie l'indonésie le
brunei les philippines le vietnam le
laos le cambodge la thaïlande et le
myanmar
c'est à dire les pays du sud est
asiatique c'est donc un p l'ange de pays
pauvres et pays riches mais parmi ces
derniers et c'est très important
on y trouve aussi la corée du sud
le japon l'australie et la nouvelle
zélande qui sont pourtant de proches
alliés de l'amérique aussi la pega et
ceci confirme le découplage en cours
entre leurs intérêts économiques
nationaux et leurs alliances
stratégiques
seuls sont absents taïwan pour des
raisons évidentes et l'inde auquel ce
traité laisse la possibilité de
rejoindre l'ensemble bien que ceci
semble peu probable j'ajouterai
également la nouvelle calédonie dont
j'ai parlé dans une émission récente il
est probable que dans le futur d'autres
pays de la zone
interrompt à l'accord ce qui renforcera
encore sa taille et sa puissance
économique
enfin il faut ajouter au pays associés
dans le rc ep l'accord global et
progressive de partenariat
transpacifique 10 et pdt paix qui a été
conclu en décembre 2018 entre sept pays
membres du rcp et trois pays d'amérique
latine le mexique le chili et le pérou
qui vont donc bénéficier à travers les
autres pays de l'intérêt du rc le p donc
cette alliance va agrandir sa zone
d'influencé et indirectement de libre
échange comme le rappelle luc barreau
chaise dans le point du 25 novembre
la croissance économique de l'asie sera
trois fois plus rapide que celle de
l'europe des etats-unis dans les dix
prochaines années et nous verrons
malheureusement pour nous dès 2021 que
la pandémie a accentué l'écart de
surcroît cet accord économique comme ce
fut le cas pour l'union européenne va
créer un cadre rang dans la zone plus
attractive pour les investisseurs
internationaux
c'est ainsi que les droits de douane
devrait réduire de 90% dans les 20 ans à
venir
favorisant les industries locales au
détriment des productions extérieures à
la zone qu'elle soit européenne ou
américaine ceci étant comme l'analyse
barthélémy courmont chercheur à l'iris
cette création ne règle pas tous les
problèmes actuels
en pesant la moitié du pib total de
l'accord le poids de la chine fait peur
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi l'un
d'eux s'était éloigné en 2019
par ailleurs il ya une vraie compétition
économique entre les principaux pays de
la zone et on peut se demander si cet
accord permettra de régler les
contentieux existants et ceux à venir
mais en dépit de tout cela pour la chine
qui réalise le tiers de ses exportations
dans la zone c'est indéniablement une
garantie de développement sécurisé à
moyen et long terme qui s'ajoutera aux
résultats des routes de la soie
enfin il est clair qu'avec cet accord le
pôle économique mondiale tant au niveau
du développement que de leur activité
est dorénavant durablement installé sur
le continent asiatique avec son
épicentre en chine
face à un président américain qui
prônaient l'arrêt des accords
internationaux au profit des bilatéraux
xi jinping dans son intervention à davos
en 2017 avait rappelé la position
chinoise elle adhérait à
l'internationalisme et à l'économie
globale pour qu'on se veut une meilleure
gouvernance mondiale pacifique et dans
ce cadre elle soutenait le libre échange
et voulait voir le multilatéralisme au
centre du jeu des affaires
internationales alors bien sûr la
plupart des commentateurs il y avait vu
une réponse politique en opposition avec
les américains le problème c'est qu'une
fois de plus les chinois ont appliqué ce
qu'ils lançaient leur insertion dans les
chaînes de valeur mondiales leur a
permis de prendre une influence
croissante dans les organisations
internationales de fédérer autour de
leurs normes et d'exercer une
attractivité croissante dont le rce
pennec la dernière manifestation visible
pour contrebalancer la création de cette
zone asiatique
l'union européenne voudrait développer
une zone d'influencé et de conditions
douanière plus vaste en tout cas dans a
marqué l'intention dans ce cadre elle
avait négocié des accords de libre
échange au niveau transatlantique avec
le mercosur
mais il faut se souvenir que la france
ayant manifesté de fortes réserves sur
les négociations extérieure menée par la
commission européenne a provoqué l'arrêt
du processus
il est intéressant de voir que dans le
même temps boris johnson qui ne perd pas
de temps tout en négociant le break site
vient de signer un accord bilatéral avec
le japon qui lui permet indirectement de
mettre un pied dans le ctp est le ver
cep et j'ajouterais qu'israël vient de
faire exactement la même chose la
semaine dernière avec la corée du sud
pour préserver sa sueur primacy
l'amérique s'est repliée sur elle-même
en rognant tout ce qui avait été le
fondement de sa politique depuis 70 ans
à savoir le libre échange et la
globalisation qu'elle défende est donc
depuis 1945
il va être très intéressant de savoir si
le nouveau président des états unis
changent de stratégie et abandonne le
protectionnisme et les pressions
commerciales et politiques
et soyons clairs c'est très peu probable
sur le fond même si l'apparence sera
évidemment différent car les lois et les
régulation américaines ont fait la
preuve de leur efficacité
en particulier on l'a bien vu en europe
tout ceci complique la vie et le
développement international des
compagnies européennes dont l'étude de
l'ifri d'octobre 2020 montre les
difficultés permanente et croissante
face aux stratégies technologiques de la
chine et des états unis prix entre les
deux hyper puissance les entreprises
françaises étaient déjà entravé par les
pratiques américaines extraterritoriale
et seul prédatrice des entreprises
chinoises elles vont se retrouver
désormais en situation concurrentielle
défavorable face aux entreprises epe
hilaire cep alors qu'il s'agit du plus
gros marché du monde est celui qui va
connaître le plus fort développement
il est triste et même inquiétant de
constater que l'europe qui a été la
première partie du monde à créer une
union douanière se retrouve aujourd'hui
marginalisée par rapport à l'air cep il
ne peut pas dire qu'elle est surprise
puisque avant les chinois le président
obama avait déjà tenté de faire la même
chose en asie souhaitons que l'europe et
la france en prenne conscience
mais en réalité l'europe est engluée
dans de multiples problèmes internes
entre toutes ses composantes aux
intérêts variés et trop souvent
divergents elle doit donc absolument
tirer les conséquences du rc ep et
trouver des solutions d'élargissement
douaniers vers le nord vers la russie et
vers l'afrique du nord vers la
méditerranée ou bien imaginer une
collaboration réelle avait un
partenariat avec le nouvel hymne ou
vos leaders asiatiques sous peine de
vivre à terme une paire de potentiel
économique et pourquoi pas d'autres
briques site
à bientôt
[Musique]